- I got stopped outside and asked
"Will you put this pill in your mouth,
"get it all over your tongue,
and then eat a donut?"
(funky upbeat music)
- So this is Crave Crush.
They're these little minty
tablets that apparently
stop you from tasting
sugar for up to an hour.
So I'm gonna go out and buy some donuts
and have my coworkers test them out
and let's see if this actually works.
Maybe it'll just ruin
donuts for them forever
and I'm just a terrible person.
But I already know that.
- I can't taste sugar for an hour?
- It smells like a mint.
- Annie has donuts, so I want
a donut so (bleep)ing badly.
(upbeat music)
- Tastes like a mint.
- Ow, God, my tongue.
It's the taste of a numbing
solution without numbness.
- I can like pop one of
these in right after a meal.
I'll have fresh breath
and I won't want sugar.
Hopefully.
- (gasps) Oh, beautiful!
- Okay, I got this maple donut.
I didn't know there would be
maple donuts and I love maple.
(upbeat music)
- Yeah, I don't taste the sweetness.
- It's like soft, like semi-sweet bread
and I don't taste the chocolate.
- No, that's still awesome.
- This is so gross.
- I do taste sugar, but it's not as, like,
overwhelming as it usually is.
- Is it sweet?
- Yeah, it's a donut.
- Yeah.
I don't taste the sweetness.
- What?
- I don't think it worked.
- This is gonna ruin
everything for me now.
- A+, Crave Crush.
(funky upbeat music)